hey wir sind wieder für euch zdf heute
live schön dass ihr bei uns im stream
seid herzlich willkommen immer wieder
gibt es in den vergangenen tagen und
auch wochen meldungen darüber dass die
ukraine die russische armee in vielen
gebieten erfolgreich zurückgedrängt und
auch gebiete zurückerobert auch heute
gibt es ein aktuelles signal das wir
sehen ukraine ist präsident sinn lenski
zu besuch in der stadt ist jung aus der
region aktiv diese stadt hat die ukraine
jetzt auch erst kürzlich zurück erobert
und auch die ukrainische staatsflagge
wird wieder in der stadt gehisst
also aktuell erfolge im kriegsverlauf
aus ukrainischer sicht und rückschläge
aus sicht von russland diese bilder und
diese signale die geben offenbar auch
der russischen protestbewegung im
eigenen land jetzt 9 auf sind denn die
stimmen des protestes sie werden lauter
sie werden mutiger so mutig dass sich
jetzt sogar ein kommunaler abgeordneten
rat mit einem offiziellen absetzung
antrag im russischen parlament gegen
wladimir putin stellt der vorwurf
hochverrat
wir hatten heute die gelegenheit vor der
sendung mit einem der initiatoren mit
nikita oft zu sprechen das ganze
interview seht ihr natürlich später auch
bei uns und später können wir die
genauen ursprünge und hintergründe
dieses protests weiter einordnen mit
leslie schübel von der körber-stiftung
fragen kommentare anregungen wie immer
gerne direkt an uns adresse wird jetzt
auch eingeblendet hätte er heute live at
zdf.de oder einfach direkt in die chats
wir haben das hier alles im blick und
versuchen so viele wie möglich zu
beantworten
thomas konsum franziska von tiesenhausen
zeigen bevor wir richtig losgehen uns
jetzt erstmal den ursprung der petition
gegen wladimir putin
sankt petersburg zentrum hier wuchs
wladimir putin auf und ausgerechnet hier
nun eine rebellion gegen ihn ein brief
von regionalabgeordneten sie haben die
staatsduma aufgefordert anklage gegen
putin zu erheben wegen volksverhetzung
ist auch in moskau am wochenende bei den
kommunalwahlen junge politiker
appellieren an putin sein amt aufzugeben
ihre rhetorik ist pure aggression und
das hat uns in die zeit des kalten
kriegs zurückversetzt die welt hat
wieder angefangen sich vor russland zu
fürchten und es zu hassen und
russland bedroht die welt wieder mit
nuklearwaffen
kritik am krieg an der kreml politik ja
an putin selbst ist das nicht gefährlich
diesen kommunalpolitiker traf anfang
juli die härte von putins justiz alexej
kudrin auf kritisierte den krieg der in
russland nicht als krieg bezeichnet
werden darf der 60-jährige habe
wissentlich falsch infos und hass
verbreitet so das gericht urteil sieben
jahre haft im straflager noch im
gerichtssaal zeigt er ein schild
aufschrift braucht ihr immer noch diesen
krieg
die kommunalpolitiker aus sankt
petersburg haben inzwischen noch mal
nachgelegt mit einer petition im
internet putin muss zurücktreten heißt
es auch dort mehr als 60 lokalpolitiker
haben unterschrieben einer der
initiatoren wurde bereits wegen
diskreditierung der armee zu einer
geldstrafe verurteilt
es geht den behörden vor allem darum zu
zeigen dass wir bestraft wurden und dass
sie ein auge auf uns haben
andererseits wollen sie aber auch nicht
zu viel öffentliche aufmerksamkeit
erregen
[Musik]
weitere unterstützer stehen ebenfalls in
sankt petersburg vor gericht
heute den tag über gefragt was soll
dieser protest bewirken welche ziele
verfolgt er aber was müssen die
beteiligten vielleicht auch für
konsequenzen erleben was spüren sie und
genau über diese fragen konnte ich heute
mit einem der mitinitiatoren sprechen
nikita verwerfen sankt petersburg
schönen guten abend
gute nacht
welche fehler wir haben es im beitrag
gesehen einer ihrer mitinitiatoren paar
yuca hat nach dem protest schon eine
geldstrafe vor gericht erhalten wir
erreichen sie heute abend auch nach
einem termin vor gericht haben sie auch
eine strafe erhalten und wenn ja welche
ich wurde zu
46.000 rubel verurteilt nur weil ich
meine stimme geben habe und meinen
verpflichtungen als abgeordneter
nachgegangen bin und ich hab ja näher an
den antrag an die staatsduma gestellt
dass putin zurücktreten soll und wie
werden die gerichtsentscheidung
anfechten ja kurz zur einordnung das
sind ungefähr 800 euro sie haben gerade
schon beschrieben sie haben die
absetzung angefordert fürchten sie durch
ihren öffentlichen appell gegen putin
auch neben der geldstrafe um ihre
persönliche sicherheit
klar gibt dass gewisse risiken
unter anderem habe ich schon drohungen
erhalten
der sprecher des
parlaments in sankt petersburg das ist
die zweite person die zweithöchste
person in der stadt
erklärt dass er mich verprügeln
was machen solche androhungen mit ihm
wir fühlen uns stark wir haben auch
unter meinen kollegen aus zwei
professionelle boxen
und kaluga hat immer offiziell
vorgeschlagen ja ein boxer kampf aus dem
boxkampf auszutragen trotzdem ist es ja
auch eine androhung von gewalt in ihrem
antrag ist auch auffällig dass sie das
wort krieg vermeiden vielleicht generell
wie sehr müssen sie gerade wenn wir das
auch hören was sie für drohungen
erhalten bei diesem protest auf ihre
wortwahl achten
das ist
es ist äußerst wichtig dass man das wort
krieg vermeiden immer wieder betonen
dass es eine spezielle militär operation
ist früher haben wir auch dieses wort
eingesetzt das ist nicht unsere erste
regierung aber es ist ja mittlerweile
mir so dass wenn man das vorgehen der
ukrainer als krieg bezeichnet dass man
ja auch durchaus zu größeren
gefängnisstrafen verurteilt wird aber
letztendlich sagen auch unsere eltern
unserer großeltern hauptsache es gibt
keinen krieg und deshalb wird das das
wort krieg nie verwendet guten hat eine
panische angst davor und die propaganda
pressiert das ebenfalls so ohne den
wahren grund dafür zu erkennen aber die
menschen werden immer
besser in ihrer einschätzung und
letztendlich kommt das wird es dazu
kommen dass die gesellschaft das ablehnt
sie gehen davon aus dass es auch einen
in der russischen gesellschaft ein
umdenken führt ihr protest sozusagen
jetzt auch wieder in erscheinung was
macht sie sicher dass dieses umdenken
auch kommt in der gesellschaft welche
eindrücke oder gespräche haben sie da
ich habe glaube nicht dass die
gesellschaft
tester veranstalten das ist sehr
gefährlich mittlerweilen ihr auf die
straße zudem zu protestieren man wird ja
von der polizei verprügelt das ist ja
einfach für jeden körperlich sehr
spürbar wie das unterdrückt wird deshalb
sehen wir notiert zukünftigen proteste
nie so sehr auf der straße sondern wir
müssen da etwas neues erfinden wir
veröffentlichen immer wieder
schreiben gegen den krieg und dafür
wurde bisher niemand
verurteilt was nun die gesellschaft
betrifft das die gesellschaft sich
verändert so kann ich das mit zahlen
belegen es gibt ja umfragen des lewada
zentrums das ist ein so genannter
ausländischer agentin der russland im
mai haben die
kampagnen der ukraine noch 72 prozent
der russen unterstützt und mittlerweile
sind es 48 prozent also unter 50 prozent
sie sprechen auch davon dass sich neue
protestformen sozusagen formieren sollen
und müssen sie selbst haben auch mit
weiteren abgeordneten schon seit beginn
der invasion russlands in diesem jahr am
24 februar auch eine kundgebung gegen
den krieg angekündigt also direkt zu
beginn und jetzt eben auch diese
position mit der absetzung wladimir
putins wegen hochverrats warum kommt ihr
protest jetzt in dem moment wo ja auch
die russische armee rückschlage
rückschläge erleidet
eigentlich hat unser rat immer wieder
dagegen protestiert angefangen am 24
februar an dem tag ich und mein kollege
viktor paltrow koch farben mit beantragt
ein anti kriegs wenig meeting
durchzuführen wir haben eine scharfe
absage bekommen wurden von der
staatsanwaltschaft
eingeladen und mein kollege musste
russland verlassen am zweiten märz war
ja eine öffentlicher sitzung unter
starters durchgeführt mit der
aufforderung den krieg sofort zu
unterbinden zu stoppen und vor unserem
gebäude tauchten auf einmal polizei buße
auf wir haben nichts desto trotz
dieses schreiben verabschiedet und haben
dafür aber weder von putin noch von
seiner administration eine antwort
bekommen wir haben auch nachdem wir
die werden zahlen von der uno gehört
haben dass über sechs millionen die
ukraine verlassen haben und über 6.000
gefallen sind beziehungsweise vernichtet
wurden rund 300 kinder darunter
habe ich dieser statistik ende ebenfalls
in ein schreiben von mir ein
beschlossener und habe an unseren
präsidenten putin geschrieben die
antwort war ganz kurz der brief ist
erhalten wurden noch weitere
konsequenzen folgen das ist nichts
danach passierten deswegen da haben wir
auch dieses schreiben an die staatsduma
fahrt fast wir hatten teilweise auch
keine gründe um damit auch unsere
aufforderung zu überlegen jetzt haben
wir die
vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz zu dem
zeitpunkt also ihre
protestbekundungen ihre petition tritt
in erscheinung in dem moment wo die
russische armee rückschläge hin nimmt
warum kommt ihr protest in diesem moment
hat das einen grund
wir haben tatsächlich uns nicht davon
leiten lassen was an der front passiert
das ist unser innerer entscheidung das
ist eine entscheidung der abgeordneten
dieses rates ich bin kein militärexperte
deswegen kann ich überhaupt nicht
abschätzen wie die lage an der front ist
wieder das ist mir bekannt dass die
russischen truppen bereits mehrmals
die besetzten gebiete verlassen mussten
abgeben mussten und geflüchtet sind es
ist also nicht der erste rock zurückzog
hey fährt auch im russischen
staatsfernsehen sehen wir jetzt
tatsächlich hitzige debatten von
ultranationalisten die da auch worte
benutzen und die kriegsführung putins
heftig kritisieren wie stehen sie zu
dieser form der kritik und was sagen
diese bilder und diese worte im
russischen staatsfernsehen aus
einerseits
ist ihre trägt dieser menschen für uns
ebenfalls inakzeptabel sie kritisieren
putin weil er zu weich ist
andererseits können sie natürlich als
unserer verbündeten
angesehen werden und er um putin
abzusetzen aber ihre rhetorik ist
inakzeptabel vor ein paar monaten werden
natürlich solche bilder worte im
staatsfernsehen tatsächlich undenkbar
gewesen die frage noch mal was würden
sie sagen starten da womöglich weitere
protest werden oder was braucht es aus
ihrer sicht damit ihr protest auch
weiter forciert werden kann
jährlich würde
keine hoffnung damit verbinden dass
diese menschen die sie gerade erwähnt
haben im offiziellen fernsehen irgendwie
unsere proteste verstärken können alles
was sie sagen es von oben diktiert
vorgegeben das ist glaube ich eine
gewisse form der propaganda es ist mir
einfach
für mich nicht vorstellbar dass putin
seine lenkt macht für das fernsehen aus
der angibt das ist nicht möglich
was würden sie sich wünschen wie wird es
in zukunft weitergehen um den protest
aus russland heraus weiter zu forcieren
die proteste in russland
sind sehr schwierig zu organisieren zu
koordinieren ich kann mir fast nicht
vorstellen dass viele menschen demnächst
auf die straßen gehen das sind ja
letztendlich
viereinhalb millionen bewaffnete
polizeibeamte
dir alles in schach halten können
200.000 die ja in
die ukraine einmarschiert sind waren die
bewaffnete streitkräfte und in im
eigenen land werden vier einer millionen
polizisten gehalten und es ist kaum
jemand bereit seine eigene gesundheit zu
riskieren
wir wissen wie
brutal die polizei das unterdrückt das
erwarte ich also nicht
und trotzdem starten sie eine petition
und einen protest vielen dank für das
gespräch
guitar hero 5 in sankt petersburg
herzlichen dank
dankeschön
dieses gespräch haben wir vor der
sendung aufgezeichnet
ich habe immer wieder auch eure
kommentare zu diesem interview im blick
und da schreibt ihr zum beispiel youtube
bei youtube ralf haberland wir feiern
solche menschen aber sie beenden auch
ihre politische karriere damit und
zerstören ihren job putin ist noch lange
nicht so schwach dass so etwas durch
geht ja das hat eine kita ja gerade auch
angesprochen aber dass er eben sich
trotzdem dagegen stellen will bei
facebook schreibt sigrid wollersheim die
erneuerung russlands muss von innen
kommen es ist zu hoffen dass dieser
prozess jetzt zb durch aktionen wie
diese angestoßen wird und die mutigen
menschen die sich gegen putin stellen
das schreibt sich wird haben meinen
allergrößten respekt hoffentlich bleiben
sie gesund ja diesen wünschen können wir
uns natürlich nur anschließen und wir
können jetzt live im stream auch gerne
weiter mit euren kommentaren und fragen
noch mal weiter sprechen über den
protest gegen putin von russischen
politikern und zwar mit leslie schübel
sie ist russland expertin bei der körber
stiftung und war bis kurz nach
kriegsbeginn auch noch in moskau guten
abend frau schübel guten
untouchable wir hören und berichten in
den vergangenen wochen viel von
ukrainischen rück eroberungen wie wir
sehen die kritik und wir haben doch
angesprochen die sogar im russischen
staatsfernsehen kommt jetzt eine
petition von kommunalen russischen
politikern die sich putin zur wehr
setzen die sich auch gegen ihn auf
bäumen die einfach sagen nein dieser
krieg dieses unrecht gegen die ukraine
und ihre bevölkerung das dulden wir
einfach nicht frage an sie aus ihrer
expertise wie sehr bröckelt da die
stärke putins in seinem eigenen land
zunächst will ich darauf hinweisen dass
in diesen aufrufen ja
sich dagegen ausgesprochen wurde was
passiert aber die waren nicht sonderlich
explizit und
ja also nicht nur das wort krieg nicht
erwähnt sondern die begründung war es
schadet russland startet den russischen
bürgerinnen und bürgern also eine sehr
innenpolitische perspektive ich glaube
dass das auch dass ich daran ist das hat
auch damit zu tun dass man damals die
leute bekommt
aber es ist auch ein anzeichen dafür
dass es nicht der große riss ist der
durch diesen krieg ausgelöst ist den
sich viele im westen bei uns erhoffen
und ich glaube dass es leider noch sehr
viel mehr braucht um die russische
führung ins wanken zu bringen
dazu kommt auch bei youtube eine frage
rein von chris j vielleicht können wir
das einmal am anfang skizzieren er fragt
nämlich worauf stützt sich denn putins
macht aktuell generell ist es daher dass
es die frage der geheimdienst oder die
armee und wer hält ihnen da eigentlich
derzeit an der macht wo liegen seine
gegner also sind viele fragen vielleicht
bleiben wir bei der ersten worauf stützt
sich putins macht aus ihrer sicht ich
glaube es wird hauptsächlich
abhängigkeiten
ich finde es also ist immer ganz gut
nachvollziehbar wenn man bedenkt dass
als putin an die macht gekommen dass er
wirklich gefeiert wurde als jemand der
das land auf räumt der dafür sorgt dass
das oligarchische system und ja die
schwierigen
verflechtungen die in den 90er jahren
entstanden sind so ein bisschen
aufgearbeitet werden und sortiert werden
und was er dann aber gemacht hat war
sein eigenes system aufzubauen im grunde
wurde nach und nach ein judo lehrer nach
dem anderen die paten seiner töchter mit
eigentlich einen sie jetzt in mächtigen
positionen sind hat er persönlich
verbindungen und die sind nicht nur
persönlich sondern auch sehr tiefgehend
verstrickt finanziell und was macht
politik angeht die meisten von den
menschen auf die sich dieses system
stützt hätten ein großes problem auch
wenn es dieses system nicht mehr geben
würde
das sind ja auch unter anderem ist es
eines der ziele dieser westlichen
unserer westlichen sanktionen dafür zu
sorgen dass ja dass diese menschen zu
spüren bekommen dass sie ihr angenehmes
leben was sie durch diese verflechtungen
und durch diese macht die quasi putin
ihn verleiht
führen können dass sie das nicht
weiterführen können und ja ich glaube
dass das das ist was dieses system
stützt gleichzeitig hat man der
gesellschaft die demokratie nie so
richtig gelernt hat meine lieblings
anekdote dazu um das zu verbildlichen
das immer es war
russland bei einer familie und die
mutter ist sein kinderzimmer gekommen
das war chaos eine deutsche mutter würde
sagen ja sieht aus wie ein schweinestall
und die russische mutter hat gesagt
mensch sieht ja aus wie einer demokratie
und ja das ist die wahrnehmung des
ganzen
ist jetzt kurz die frage noch mal genau
also sie lernt das ja schon skizziert
ein ein system das aus vielen geflechten
besteht und da passt auch ganz kurz von
manu es bei youtube einfach die frage
geht es dann so einfach auch diesen
präsidenten aus dem amt zu heben
beziehungsweise könnte er sich dagegen
wehren und das haben sie eigentlich
beschrieben also es ist so sehr
verstrickt innerlich und auch eine kita
dass er bei uns eingeordnet dass er
selber auch nicht davon ausgeht dass
jetzt der antrag den kompletten die
komplette wucht entfalten kann
tatsächlich dafür sorgen zu sorgen putin
aus dem aus dem amt zu heben gehen sie
mit der einschätzung mit
absolut ich würde sogar ja auch noch mal
betonen wollen dass es sehr
unwahrscheinlich ist dass es
irgendwelche großen proteste hervorruft
ich halte es für unwahrscheinlich dass
es überhaupt besonders groß wahrgenommen
wird in der russischen bevölkerung bei
denjenigen die sich mit oppositionellen
medien informieren wird das definitiv
auf dem schirm sein ich habe heute mal
die
ersten seiten von den üblichen
russischen größten russischen zeitungen
die von den meisten russen großen
gelesen werden die zeitung lesen
mehrmals angeschaut und da also kein
wort zu diesem thema ich habe einen
kleineren artikeln ich glaube dass das
was großes auslöst ist sehr sehr
unwahrscheinlich
ich glaube trotzdem das ist sehr wichtig
ist dass sowas passiert das auch die
russische bevölkerung immer wieder das
gefühl hat okay also die menschen
die sich gegen dieses regime stellen und
die versuchen das zu machen und die ihre
sicherheit und
ihre zukunft aufs spiel setzen dafür um
sich gegen dieses regime
zu stellen ja das auch für die es
wichtig ist zu sehen sie sind nicht
alleine es gibt immer wieder leute die
was versuchen ich halte es für extrem
unwahrscheinlich dass das jetzt neu das
bei uns im westen erhoffte ergebnis hat
dass das regime wirklich bröckelt oder
das ist zu großen protesten kommt in
einem russlands ja und eine dieser
stimmen haben wir ja auch gemeinsam
gehörten kita juve und sie sprechen das
an dass das eine durchaus der
gefährliche situation dann ist oder sein
kann ich meine ändern wir uns erinnern
wir uns an den fall navalny und da da
fragt auch richard pietraß bei youtube
stellt sich eben die frage ob jetzt
wirklich die abgeordneten um ihr leben
fürchten müssen
also ich glaube dass diejenigen die das
unterschrieben haben ehrlich gesagt
nicht wichtig genug sind nicht präsent
genug sind dass sie da auf
eine novität vergiftung wie im fall
einer wein befürchten müssen aber krasse
repressionen müssen sie definitiv
befürchten wir haben in dem film kurz
von alexej kurilow aufgehört sein
kollege jaschin ist auch immer noch
verhaftet viele oppositionelle sind
längst aus dem land raus und ich kann
sehr gut verstehen wieso und sind auch
nicht nur diese menschen die so
öffentlich auf die straße gehen sondern
oder öffentlich sich politisch äußern
sondern auch diejenigen die zu protesten
gehen also es wird
teilweise mit digitalen kameras mit
gesichtserkennung wird festgestellt wer
daraus geht werde er sich öffentlich
äußert und für die person bedeutet das
dann nicht nur dass sie ihre eigene
zukunft aufs spiel setzen dass sie
selber ihren job verlieren
hohe geldstrafen erwarten müssen dass
sie ins gefängnis kommen sondern auch
dass die mutter den job verliert das der
oma die rente gekürzt wird dass die
kleine schwester den studienplatz nicht
bekommen dass man im krankenhaus
abgewiesen wird also es gibt sehr sehr
viele maßnahmen die dazu führen dass es
nicht meine entscheidung für ein selber
ist auf die straße zu gehen sondern man
auch für menschen die einem nahe sind
mit entscheidet oft und ja das verändert
die situation natürlich noch mal sehr
sie haben das gerade schon angesprochen
dass das was sie heute den tag über
gecheckt haben dass da die reaktionen im
netz oder auch vielleicht austeilen dann
des netzes in russland aus der
bevölkerung da relativ gering ausfallen
was müsste denn aber passieren dass die
menschen in russland sich stärker auf
lehnen dass sie vielleicht sogar auf die
straße gehen gegen diesen krieg sehen
sie da vielleicht generell ein szenario
wo da wirklich etwas entstehen könnte ja
das ist sie million dollar question
ich glaube dass es insgesamt sehr sehr
unwahrscheinlich ist dass aus der
russischen bevölkerung so was entsteht
so eine protestbewegung entsteht in
naher zukunft ich glaube wenn es da
veränderung geben kann dann müssten die
innerhalb der russischen elite
entstehen dann müssten oben brüche sein
so dass diese leute die so viel aufs
spiel setzen wenn sie auf die straße
gehen das gefühl haben das führt zu was
weil was jetzt gerade da es ist dieses
große gefühl von das bringt eh nichts
wir können eh nichts ausrichten
wir tun uns nur selber weh und am ende
erreichen wir nichts und ich glaube wenn
es innerhalb der eliten sichtbare risse
geben würde und dazu gehört leider nicht
das sowieso oppositionell eingestellte
kommunalpolitikerinnen und politiker in
moskau und petersburg
sich also petitionen veröffentlichen
dann kann ich mir vorstellen dass damals
geben kann aktuell sehe ich nicht dass
es überhaupt jemanden gibt der so viele
leute hinter sich vereinen kann so eine
bewegung braucht irgendjemanden der
führt
navalny ist hinter gittern auf
unabsehbare zeit einer der wenigen
letzten die noch übrig waren der
politiker aus ekaterinburg
jetzt gegen iris mann ist inzwischen
auch verhaftet worden
es wird enger und ich glaube leider dass
das was jetzt gerade in russland sehen
ja nicht nicht unbedingt ein gutes
zeichen ist sondern vielleicht eher dazu
führt oder wahrscheinlich eher dazu
führt dass diese menschen die sich da
jetzt geäußert haben
repression zum opfer fallen und noch
weniger diversität in den meinungen in
den sowieso schon nicht demokratisch
gewählten parlamenten und vertretungen
gibt in russland
wir sind beim system putin wir sind beim
system dass dieses ganze land umfasst
und wir sind dann auch bei den gesetzes
gegebenheiten wenn wir da auch über die
strafen sprechen die solche
politikerinnen und politiker die sich
auflehnen dann befürchten die haben wir
besprochen und eine frage kommt auch bei
youtube.com user namen homer simpson und
seine frage wäre was denn in diesem
zusammenhang also der vorwurf konkret
bedeutet also dieser hochverrat was was
heißt das in diesem land
naja also in dem kontext sehen wir
gerade gesehen haben ist der hochverrat
natürlich dass das putin vorgeworfen
wird ich denke das ist eine art von
hochverrat wie wir ihn alle verstehen
würden der hochverrat in dem narrativ
der russischen propaganda also das was
dann den menschen die sich gegen die
regierung auflehnen
der ist natürlich was anderes und
ehrlich gesagt einfach etwas ausgedacht
ist im grunde alles was das system
hinterfragt wird als hochverrat
eingestuft
und
also ich finde immer wichtig zu sagen
diese frage ist auch in unserem
rationalen denkens gestellt ganz viel
was da in russland passiert ist nicht
rational die begründung das weswegen in
der ukraine dieser grausamen krieg
geführt wird ist nicht rational
auch verhandlungen mit putin fühlen ist
so schwierig weil es nicht rational ist
was dann gut oder schlecht eingeschätzt
wird weil man nicht sagen kann okay wir
gehen auf ihn zu oder nicht sondern ist
es ganz viel ausgedacht das ist ganz
viel irrational und im grunde kann
hochverrat in dem sinne als alles
interpretiert werden je nachdem wie sehr
die person gerade stört in den augen er
macht
sie beschreiben das irrational und
ideologie behaftet
eine abschlussfrage vielleicht noch von
einem user von marvin bega auch wenn sie
natürlich noch mal
geschrieben haben detailliert wie
ausgefeilt dieses geflecht und dieses
system putin in russland ist
es ist eine poetische szenario aber
marvin becker fragt welche szenarien
könnte man sich denn in zukunft
vorstellen nach einem eventuellen fall
putins gibt es da schon studien theorien
zu oder oder diskussion in der in der
gesellschaft was würde das bedeuten
wissen sie da was drüber
in der gesellschaft
ich glaube einer russischen gesellschaft
wird in die richtung wenig gedacht viel
davon ist wunschdenken
ehrlich gesagt weiß man auch nicht also
eine wie ich schon erwähnt habe wer
seine rolle aus führen könnte ich glaube
bei den menschen mit denen ich
gesprochen habe die sich mit der
situation auch viel auseinandersetzen
ist er ein bisschen pessimismus dabei
dass auch ein ende des regimes putin
nicht dazu führen würde dass wir es mit
einem demokratischen russland zu tun
hätten sondern das wie gesagt diese
strukturen sehr sehr tief verankert sind
und
ich befürchte dass es ein sehr sehr lang
lang eines langen prozesses bedarf bis
sich da irgendwas tun kann und all das
leider für sehr unwahrscheinlich dass es
demnächst passieren wird für einen sehr
sehr langen prozess sagt leslie schübel
hierbei zdf heute live von der
körber-stiftung russland expertin ist
sie und frau schübel ich glaube sie
sagen es ist ein langer prozess und ich
glaube mit der stimmung im chat und auch
mit einem kommentar von danke für deine
antwort auf youtube dass russland auf
jeden fall mehr von solchen mutigen
menschen die heute hier bei uns gehört
im stream braucht ich glaube damit
können wir an der stelle glaube ich auch
raus gehen was sagen sie auf jeden fall
ist er andere diese menschen sehr und
wünsche russland und diesen menschen die
sich das trauen nur das beste vielen
herzlichen dank für ihre einschätzungen
und die einblicke und ihre zeit hier bei
zdf heute live da ging ich
danke euch natürlich auch sehr fürs
zuschauen für eure fragen für höhere
auch eure auch positiven rückmeldungen
zu nikita der sich hier geäußert hat zu
einer protestbewegung von russischen
politikern gegen wladimir putin das war
es von uns für heute bis zum nächsten
mal macht's gut und noch einen schönen
haben